Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Et si je vous disais
qu’on peut se nourrir d’amour ?
Des rires,
des jeux, des relations,
des spiritualités.
Je suis Odette Haddad,
et aujourd’hui,
j’aimerais vous faire découvrir
les pouvoirs de l’alimentation consciente.
Je suis née en Colombie,
j’y ai grandi jusqu’à mes 25 ans.
Mes grands-parents libanais sont arrivés
en Colombie dans les années 30.
Ils y ont fait leur vie.
On a hérité d’eux
beaucoup de la culture libanaise :
on parle fort à table,
on se mêle de tout
et on pense à la nourriture tout le temps.
Au déjeuner, on pense déjà
à ce qu’on va manger pour le dîner.
Tout événement est une belle excuse
pour se réunir en famille,
bien manger ensemble, fêter la famille.
J’ai grandi dans le confort.
Je suis allée dans une école privée,
j’ai fait de très longues études.
J’ai commencé ma carrière dans
une grande entreprise agro-alimentaire.
Je m’apprêtais à poursuivre
le chemin attendu,
à cocher toutes les cases :
bonnes études, bon travail,
maison, famille,
mais cette perspective
ne collait pas du tout
avec ce que je voulais
vraiment faire de ma vie.
Je savais que je ne voulais pas travailler
pour une grande multinationale,
mais plutôt pour le commerce équitable,
un concept pas très
connu en Colombie à ce moment-là,
mais surtout, je savais que je voulais
un métier qui ait du sens pour moi.
J’ai toujours été une grande rêveuse.
Je n’arrêtais pas d’entendre
cette petite voix dans ma tête,
ou plutôt dans mon cœur, qui me disait :
« Non, non, non, ce n’est pas par là
qu’il faut aller, ma grande. »
Un jour, j’ai décidé d’écouter
cette petite voix.
J’avais étudié le français à l’université
et c’est grâce au programme des filles
au pair que je suis arrivée en France.
Après 8 mois, j’ai réussi
à m’inscrire en Master 2 en économie
solidaire et logique de marché.
J’ai trouvé un stage chez Artisans
du monde dans le commerce équitable,
où j’ai rencontré Tristan,
mon mari et mon associé.
Vous voyez, il faut toujours
écouter cette petite voix.
En 2015,
inspirés par nos parcours professionnels
et par ma passion pour la cuisine,
nous avons décidé
de lancer notre propre projet,
Un projet qui de sens.
Au même moment qu’on devenait parents,
nous avons ouvert le premier
bar à jus bio de Versailles.
C'était une petite cantine de midi
où je faisais la cuisine.
La carte changeait tous les jours.
Rapidement, j’ai commencé
à organiser des ateliers de cuisine.
C’était un espace pour échanger
avec mes clients, partager mes recettes,
mais surtout pour passer
un très bon moment ensemble.
Voulant aller plus loin, je me suis formée
en nutrition holistique à New York,
et j’ai continué à animer mes ateliers,
maintenant avec une approche
plus holistique de l’alimentation.
Deux ans plus tard,
nous avons ouvert « Le Positive Café »,
un restaurant flexitarien,
et le petit bar à jus est devenu
la « Positive Academy ».
C’est là où je continue
mes ateliers aujourd’hui
et c’est toujours avec un grand plaisir
que j’y rencontre mes clients.
Plus j’anime les ateliers,
plus je me rends compte qu’on n’est
pas tous là juste pour faire la cuisine,
mais plutôt pour cuisiner ensemble,
pour rigoler,
pour échanger, pour nous nourrir
de l'énergie des autres.
Vous avez déjà entendu parler
des zones bleues ?
Une zone bleue est une région où l’on
trouve plus de centenaires que la moyenne.
[La première] a été identifiée
dans les années 2000 en Sardaigne.
Plus tard, quatre autres régions
ont été découvertes :
Okinawa au Japon,
Nicoya au Costa Rica, Icarie en Grèce
et Loma Linda en Californie.
Dans des quartiers d’Okinawa,
il y a ces groupes de soutien social
qui s’appellent Moai.
Ce sont des amis de longue date
qui se retrouvent dans un but commun,
parfois tous les jours,
parfois quelques jours par semaine,
pour échanger,
pour se donner des conseils,
pour s’entraider financièrement
si c’est nécessaire.
Ils deviennent une famille.
A Nicoya au Costa Rica,
les habitants ont cette habitude
de définir un « plan de vie »,
une raison de vivre, en français.
C’est un objectif de vie qui les motive
et les imprègne d’une attitude positive,
les aide à rester actifs,
notamment les personnes âgées.
Icarie en Grèce et la Sardaigne
sont sans doute deux des régions les
plus propices à une bonne alimentation.
Grâce à leur situation géographique
et à leur climat,
les habitants ont développé une cuisine
et une alimentation très équilibrées,
riches en poissons,
en légumineuses, en vin.
Enfin, à Loma Linda, en Californie,
ce sont 9 000 adventistes qui sont
au cœur de cette zone bleue.
Leur longévité peut être attribuée
à leur végétarisme
et à leur activité physique régulière.
Par ailleurs, grâce à leur religion,
les adventistes ne fument pas
et ne boivent pas d’alcool.
Les habitants de ces zones bleues
partagent trois caractéristiques.
Ils nourrissent leur corps à travers
une alimentation principalement végétale.
Avec le mouvement, le repos,
ils nourrissent leur mental
par les jeux et le travail.
Ils nourrissent leur esprit
par la méditation et la prière.
L’observation de ces populations montre
qu’ils passent du temps entre amis,
qu’ils vivent souvent entre générations
avec les enfants ou les petits-enfants.
Ils sont physiquement actifs et passent
une grande partie de leur temps
à cultiver, à récolter et à cuisiner
les produits de leur potager.
Ils ont une raison
de se lever chaque matin.
Ils remercient, ils prient.
Je m’identifie beaucoup
à ces populations qui sourient à la vie,
malgré leur situation
souvent très précaire.
Ils ont ce sentiment d’appartenir à une
communauté, d’être importants, utiles.
Ces mêmes sentiments que je recherchais,
que nous recherchons tous finalement.
Ils ont tout compris du pouvoir
de l’alimentation consciente.
Souvent, dans mes ateliers,
quand je parle d’alimentation principale,
les gens pensent à ça.
Mais en réalité, mon alimentation
principale ressemble plutôt à ça.
Ce qui me nourrit vraiment aujourd’hui :
mon mari et mes deux enfants qui me
rappellent chaque jour ma raison de vivre.
Mon travail, ma cuisine.
Pouvoir la partager avec vous.
Enfin, pouvoir passer de temps
avec mes amis, avec ma famille.
Tout ce que je vis aujourd’hui,
je l’ai imaginé, manifesté,
et je remercie l’univers
chaque jour de ma vie.
Aujourd’hui, je sais que
tout est raison d’être.
Je sais que l’on peut devenir ce que
l’on souhaite, vivre ses rêves,
se nourrir différemment.
Et vous, qu’est-ce qui vous fait vibrer ?
C’est quoi, votre plan de vie ?
Qui sont les personnes qui vous font
vous sentir important, utile ?
Quelle est la raison pour laquelle
vous vous levez chaque matin ?
Vous souvenez-vous, enfant,
quand vous jouiez dehors avec une toupie
et que votre maman vous appelait à table ?
Vous vouliez juste rester et jouer.
Vous ne vouliez pas aller à table,
vous vouliez juste rester jouer,
vous n’aviez pas faim du tout.
Ou quand vous êtes tombé
amoureux pour la première fois ?
Une alimentation consciente,
saine, équilibrée,
nourrit certes notre corps physique,
mais il nourrit aussi notre mental,
notre curiosité, notre cœur.
Voilà le vrai pouvoir
d’une alimentation consciente :
pouvoir exploiter tout notre potentiel à
travers des activités que l’on aime faire
et dans lesquelles on peut faire
preuve de créativité.
Une alimentation qui nous permet
de donner un vrai sens à notre vie.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)